Dozens of protests erupted
on university campuses and in cities
across China on Saturday.
In an unprecedented
show of defiance
and anger
against the government's
restrictive zero COVID policy,
many shouted for leader
Xi Jinping and the Communist Party
to step down.
A deadly fire at an apartment
building in the far
western region
of Xinjiang appears to be fueling
the most recent anger
as video emerged,
which appeared to show lockdown measures
delayed firefighters
from reaching the victims.
Now, in an op ed published
Sunday morning,
Chinese state
media calls the current COVID
measures, quote,
scientifically effective.
Saying the public
should have full confidence in them.
All right.
Let's get the latest from CNN's
Beijing bureau chief, Stephen Jiang.
Stephen, we've seen
isolated protests before,
but do these seem different
in terms of the size and the scale
That's why this wave of protests
really triggered
by that
deadly Xinjiang fire
you just mentioned,
but also how the authorities are handled,
the aftermath,
because on one hand,
they reject the claims
that their
COVID measures
had anything to do
with the firefighters inability
to reach the fire quickly.
But on the other hand,
after insisting for weeks and months
that COVID situation
in Xinjiang was so severe and lockdowns
must be maintained, all of a sudden
they announce this miraculous victory
in their campaign
and also a phased reopening.
So I think all of that really serving
as the latest
and loudest wake up
call to a lot of people
in terms
of how increasingly
ineffective, unscientific
And not to mention potentially dangerous
this zero COVID that policy has become.
And also, of course,
all the absurdities
surrounding its enforcement.
That's why why
we have seen people
across this country
really
trying to take the matter
into their own hands.
Not only you see people in Xinjiang
taking to the streets,
demanding their freedom,
clashing with security forces,
but also even here in Beijing,
for example,
residents are seeing tearing down
metal barriers
or fences,
set up
a set up by local officials
to seal them off in their residences.
But all of that really culminating
Saturday night
into Sunday morning with multiple vigils
and protests
often spearheaded
by young people on university campuses.
You know,
they are seen holding up white paper,
white obviously
being the color of mourning,
not only for the victims of Xinjiang,
but also trying to,
as they seem to trying to indicate
there was so much anger and frustration
pent up inside themselves
and that they were not allowed
to express them.
Because, remember,
for a lot of these university students,
their entire college life has been under
some form of a lockdown can
it's looking at the video.
You see how big the protests are.
You see the police presence there.
You talked about clashes
with authorities.
Is there a chance that the crackdown
on the protests
might turn more violent,
maybe even deadly
That is a potential worry
because when you look at these protests,
I think they are widespread,
as you mentioned.
But that one extraordinary protest,
you place some of the
the sound
and the introduction was the one
taking place in downtown Shanghai
on Saturday night
because the protester there
really chanting slogans directly
targeting the ruling Communist Party
and its strongman leader, Xi Jinping.
That was just such a watershed moment
in the minds of many people
because so far, even
the opponents of the policy
have been dancing around this
quite a bit in terms
of saying
the policy
may not be all wrong and the leadership
really
their heart was in the right place.
But blaming local enforcement
and pointing a finger
at as overzealous
or incompetent local officials.
But those protesters in Shanghai
really directly
challenging the legitimacy
of the Communist Party and its leader.
That, as you know, is something
simply not tolerated here.
So that's why
there was a lot of concern, worry
about the protesters.
Some of them have been taken away
by by police Windows ten.
That's why
a crowd has again gathered up in Shanghai
on the same location
demanding their release.
So I think
there was a lot of concern there,
but not to mention, of course,
from the government's
perspective, there was also a lot of fear
that this kind of chanting and protest
could inspire others across this country.
Yeah, absolutely.
We'll keep an eye on this important story
throughout the morning.
Steven Zhang, thanks so much.